i think if faze had an air jordan 1
sneaker
it'd be over they'd be the coolest shoe
ever you definitely have to do the red
tiger camo from call of duty with the
phase in it with the air jordan ones
i mean they'd probably be the best
selling air jordan one of all time
started out there hey what's going on gq
i'm face swag and this is my life and
sneakers
[Music]
air dior jordan 1 collab there's a story
to these shoes we had just 100 000
tournament on warzone
and we were at dinner i had took in a
few shots and i went on the sneaker app
i don't know why i think i was waiting
for my food and i saw the dior jordan
ones and uh i started just like
ah 11k that doesn't sound too bad i mean
the tournament can cover that so i just
swiped right and bought them so it was
more so like a gift to myself for
winning the tournament that's kind of
the story behind i was a little tipsy
when i bought these i don't regret it
though i wear them everywhere i saw
multiple like celebrities rocking these
shoes and i think i went to a store and
i saw them like in a case and this is
before i joined fade this is before like
i was i was i was still doing youtube
but i saw how the price tag for i said
who in the world would buy those like
what's the why like why spend that much
money on kicks and then you fast forward
a year and a half later
yeah i have no regrets getting these at
all and i think one of the things like
people were saying is i should resell
them but i'm like i bought these for me
and i wear them literally all the time
like i think that's what a shoe is you
know
i could put them in a case and keep them
forever but it's like you know they're
they're shoes man i'm gonna rock them
the number on these are six thousand
nine hundred eight out of eighty five
hundred i don't even i don't even wow
my newest pair of sneakers that i
actually have are going to be definitely
the kobe 2k gamer exclusive ones this
was a gift to me by twitch shout out to
twitch for doing sports illustrated
cover they sent me these and these are
my newest pair i haven't even taken out
the the paper inside them they're
they're completely brand new like three
days ago i got them like they have like
the twitch colors on them too so it's
pretty cool as far as the kobe 5's i
really love the low top it was the first
shoe where i really felt comfortable in
a low top i wore high tops a lot i wore
like different lebron shoes where they
were high tops but when i found these
kobe low tops they were just dope i love
this design right here his signature on
the back was really cool um the mamba
logo on the front as well was always so
dope and then obviously i have the mama
logo on the bottom as well it felt good
on the court too my brother tells me
that he thinks i should just not i
should just leave them on ice but uh to
be honest i'll probably wear them and
play basketball in them that's probably
going to do with these you know kobe's
man they're just made to made a hoop in
my favorite player growing up uh had to
be kobe we were born in l.a my dad was a
lakers fan my grandpa his dad was a
lakers fan so growing up that was just
our icon that was who we looked up to
anything basketball wise was kobe bryant
i think my rarest pair of kicks that i
have are definitely going to be the air
force one v-lone collab i literally
never see anybody with these these are
some of the coolest kicks this was a
gift from another phase member the shoe
is just so fire the colorway the orange
the black it just can't get any better i
think the resale rate for the v-lone air
force ones are around like 3 700 i think
these are size 14 they actually fit me
my oldest pair of sneakers that i
actually have are the balenciaga speed
runners it's really like a sock i wore
them everywhere i go go grocery store i
go eat go to school in them i mean i
wore them everywhere you know if i'm
gonna pay that much money i'm gonna wear
the sneaker all the time so i remember
when my first big check on youtube i i
bought these i really wanted these so
bad i just started seeing a lot of
athletes and rappers um i think even
like cardi b rapped about it in a song
they look good on everybody so i think
designer stinkers are definitely dope
but i don't really rock that many
designer sneakers so but yeah these are
probably the only ones i ever really
wanted
i'd say they're probably the ugliest
pair in my collection the union fours
they're just so different like the big
yellow on the bottom i think this is a
gift these were a gift i definitely
appreciate the gift i think their cool
shoes is the colorway is a little
different with these like i said you
have like this bright like lime like
lemon lime color right here and then you
have inside it has like a orange and
then you have like red black blue and
there's just so many different colors on
them and then i got the bottom they're
just so they're so different i'm not a
huge fan of the fours i think they're
dope and they're they're definitely
comfy my brother loves rocking them but
i'm my favorite and the only ones i
really enjoy wearing are the ones ones
are just so iconic they look good with
any outfit
but the fours are definitely tough as
well
i think my most beat up pair of shoes
are definitely the air jordan ones the
breads these are my first pair of air
jordan ones and when i wore them they
went with so many outfits i just started
to wear them everywhere i went so it'd
be like an athletic wear i'd throw on
some basketball shorts a t-shirt to the
clubs with jeans you know nice little
jacket feeling good go over to mom's for
a cookout i'm wearing these like
everywhere i went i was going i was
going with the breads i think i maybe
hooped in these one time as well too but
yeah these are my most beat up
parachutes by far yeah for the ones the
reason why i think they're so iconic is
just the way the high tops look and feel
it's so comfortable and they look so
good with so many different outfits you
know they don't look like clown feet you
know because i wear size 13 so the ones
are gonna look big but they don't look
that big on my feet they look stylish
they look awesome and um i think it's
the iconic the way the high tops just
feel and look and with the breads as
well the colorway the red with the black
it was just so they're just so dope
we have the 97s the air maxes couple
years ago i used to have an all-white
pair they were my favorite shoe
everywhere i went they go with any
outfit i used to rock them all the time
and then i saw mischief did it
collaboration with air max the jesus
shoes the holy waters right here i
thought it was just so unique and so
different
and just so dope the water at the bottom
of them from the jordan river they got
the cross the front of the shoe i am
christian so i thought i thought it was
also really cool and just and just dope
got the matthew 14 25 on the other side
as well too i just thought it was such a
cool collab you know i love the 97s i
rocked them anywhere and to have this
sort of collab was awesome this [ __ ] did
it killed it killed it yeah mischief
also made a pair with a little knots x
uh as far as like the satan shoe yeah
those were in my opinion those were a
little od might wouldn't have gotten
them but um
yeah they were going for it so
i think i had a human blood in them i
was like
[Music]
like i said i love collaborations and
what travis scott did with the air
jordan ones so cool and they're so
unique and i love the brown i never
really thought brown would look good on
a shoe and then you throw on pink laces
but then i saw him with outfits and i
was like hey those are crazy so i had to
get them they're so different you got
the flip swoosh sign one of my cool
favorite things on this shoe that no one
really notices is the cactus jack right
here on the side as well it's really
dope and then like i said i think the
coolest part is the pink laces you would
have never thought about a brown shoe
pink laces but it works it just works
[Music]
i think he kills it every time like i
love his vision and the way they're just
so different than any other sneaker i've
seen um like i said these are the new
sixes that he just dropped very dope i
mean you wouldn't think like this
colorway i would have never thought this
would work but uh with so many different
outfits they just look so stylish and so
clean and i kind of like a shoe when
it's kind of loud but also stylish as
well you know what i mean like you're
buying a sneaker
you know to kind of like
not they don't go under the radar you
once gonna be like whoa those are dope
and i think that's what he's done with
jordan thank you
to join cactus gaming
i would never leave face that's i don't
even know cactus what what i don't know
what we're talking about right now next
question
my top five sneakers in my collection
this was tough but i have a pretty clear
reason why this is my top five so i
think first of all obviously we gotta go
with the uh dior air jordan ones no need
much explaining they just have to be in
your top five i think my next ones are
gonna be my shattered backboards i think
just the orange when you have the right
fit they pop out so much and people
notice them right away and they're just
such a cool shoe with the shiny effect
with the orange i think it's definitely
in my top five i love wearing them and
they're so comfortable next up for my
top five probably the ben and jerry's
the dunks the colorway is so crazy but
it works and like i said i love a shoe
that's kind of loud but also stylish
i've got my most compliments in these
shoes my fourth favorite is definitely
gonna have to be the holy waters
definitely the jesus shoes for sure just
because you know they're all white and
they go with any fit so they have to be
in your top five they're like in any
emergency oh you don't have a certain
shirt just throw these on and they'll go
with any outfit so to round out the top
five for my sneakers is definitely gonna
be
it's definitely gonna be i think the
travis scotts i think the travis scotts
are just so dope and um like i said they
go with a lot of outfits too and with
the pink lace they stand out so that's
gonna round on my top five sneakers yeah
i don't know if anyone can be my
starting five we'll have to see though
to take two of these out to have my top
three
i think i'm taking out the travis scott
and wow you didn't do this to me i think
i'm gonna take out the shattered
backboards
ev i love these shoes so much it's so
hard to take out of my
but these are my top three got the ben
and jerry's air jordan one air diors and
then the 97 is the jesus shoes those are
my top three shoes i want to give a big
shout out to gq for having me um it was
awesome you guys checked out my sneaker
collection make sure you guys go in the
comments let me know what your favorite
sneaker was and uh yeah anyways guys
face swag